oh
uh
[Music]
so three presidents here in new york
today led by president biden president
clinton president obama also in the
crowd along with many dignitaries both
from washington
the mayor of new york here as well
had been speculated that potentially
president trump would also be coming
along today of course a native new
yorker um hasn't been spotted in the
crowd at this stage but he has said that
he will
mark the anniversary of 911 in his own
way
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
get a um
[Music]
oh my gosh
the moment of silence
we just shared
marks the very moment 20 years ago that
american airlines
flight 11 flew into the north tower of
the world trade center
my name is mike lowe and my daughter
sarah elizabeth lowe was a flight
attendant on that plane
these 20 years have felt like both a
long time
and a short time
and as we recite the names of those we
lost
my memory goes back to that terrible day
when it felt like an evil specter had
descended on our world
but it was also a time when many people
acted above
and beyond the ordinary
beginning with the actions of the flight
crews
like sarah
and the passengers on the four flights
the individuals in the towers
the professionals of the fire and police
and later the volunteers
who have worked on the pile sensitive to
recovering
our loved ones remains
they helped pull us through the darkest
days of our lives
in the last 20 years my family and i
have at times known unbearable sorrow
and disbelief about the lives
that would never be
years we have
filled with speaking out on my
daughter's behalf
and calling on many more precautions
and also for the history to be
remembered
not as numbers and a date
but the faces of ordinary people
people who looked a lot like sarah
at the first memorial ceremony
my wife bobby and i
stood here with thousands of family
members
right in the midst of a gray and black
world of destroyed buildings
today this is a quiet place of memory
the gleaming 911 museum
holds a sacred repository for our loved
ones remains
and the still brightening stories of all
the sons and daughters the siblings
husbands and wives grandparents and
friends
as we carry these 20 years forward i
find sustenance and a continuing
appreciation for all of those
who
rose to be more than ordinary people
and a father's pride in his daughter's
selfless acts in the last moments of her
life
acting with heroic calm to help those in
the air and those on the ground
a legacy from sarah
that burns like an eternal flame
gordon m amith junior
edelmiro abad
marie rose abbad
andrew anthony abate
vincent paul abate
lawrence christopher abell
alana abraham
william
f
abrahamson
richard anthony achetto
heinrich bernard ackermann
paul aqua viva
christian
she was only 28 years old she logged
only a few years as a flight attendant
before boarding the california bound
flight in boston's logan airport in the
early hours
of 9 11. joseph
authorities believe that sarah had given
her telephone calling card to a fellow
flight attendant madeleine amy sweeney
he used an effort to relay critical
information to the ground her father
speaking about his pride in his daughter
today as we continue to hear the names
being read out here at ground zero
severe ahmed
terence andre aiken
godwin
o ajala
trudy m alagero
andrew alameno
margaret ann alario
gary
m albero
john leslie albert
peter craig
alderman
and my brother vladimir sivinkin
vladik
we all love and miss you so much
thank you for answering our prayers and
showing us that you're always with us i
look at your my your nephew's face
and i see you in his face sometimes and
i cherish those moments
twenty years have gone by and so much
has changed in our lives
but the memory of you and keeping you
close to us
and cherishing the gifts of your life
never changes and never will
watch
it
and my father
edward joseph papa
dad
we miss you every day
our greatest gifts are your beautiful
grandchildren
they embody your kind spirit
warm heart
loving nature
and zest for life
they are daily reminder that your legacy
lives on
we love you dad